the direction taken by European interior
ministers is highly controversial among
human rights activists Thursday's debate
focused on speeding up the return of
migrants who have been denied Asylum CEO
Napoleon path if we don't succeed in
controlling our external borders there's
an enormous risk that the Schengen
system will not survive you know the
system Shannon of Apache leave The
ministers have proposed a series of
deportation measures they include
significantly boosting the capacities of
the EU Border Agency Frontex that will
pave the way to financing collective
deportation flights to the migrants
countries of origin look feeling is in
my heart repatriation is always
difficult if we make this decision and
differentiate between those who need
protection and those who don't it will
be difficult for those who don't need
protection to have to leave Europe
delegations from the Balkan countries
were also invited the EU needs their
assistance in repatriating economic
migrants whose asylum requests are
denied gathering together all the key
actors with a common purpose with common
views I think it's a good way of dealing
with that the Balkan states willingness
to cooperate will likely depend on the
amount of financial help they receive in
return the EU was under pressure to
reach a deal